I've been dying to talk about this one
and because it's a slow news day I get
to I have this tweet from Elon Musk no
doubt replying to me saying Tim pool's
right thank you uh Elon Musk responded
to me saying some truth to this so some
agreement there when I defined wokeness
and here we have this tweet of uh Elon
Musk I'm sorry I'm just making fun of
Luke gradkowski because when he was when
he was on the show and Elon followed him
he started walking around the house
making sure everybody knew that Elon
started following her and he was just
walking around with his close personal
friend he was smiling and he was like
hey uh did you guys hear and like what's
happened he's like oh Elon followed me
and everyone's like okay Luke so that's
what happens we start working out I hope
Luke's listening here's the tweet I said
understanding what woke is is simple I
like how it says is is it is the modern
left liberal culture created by
algorithms on social media it is
characterized by cult-like adherence to
rapidly changing ideological foundations
rooted in various leftist theories it is
social zombism that's it that's it
everybody hyper focuses on one element
or one aspect of the modern culture of
the left I disagree with completely
ignorant of the fact that those of us
and there are many many others who have
been doing this long than I have those
of us who have been tracking the culture
War for a long time have seen so many
different forms of whatever wokeness is
you begin to realize after the first few
years there is no ideology first it was
feminism then it was intersectional
feminism then it was intersectionality
it was feminism intersectional feminism
intersectionality as a whole which
started including a bunch of other
components to it then it became critical
theory critical race Theory critical
gender Theory and ultimately wokeness
all it means simply put it's the modern
left liberal culture that has been
formed by social media algorithms it is
the political equivalent to a teenage
girl crying because people won't like
her Instagram photo of her butt that's
what it is these people go on social
media their world is politics and they
want to get as many likes as possible
end of story I have some questions about
your definition yeah sure let me give
you an example real quick so you can
understand here's a tweet from genk
yuger he says I don't even know if quote
Equity is a real thing that anyone
outside of 12 leftists and the entire
right wing believe is real the
overwhelming majority of progressives
agree with Bernie Sanders and me that
equality of opportunity is the right
standard well hold on there mister how
can Joe Biden have a national Equity
initiative how can every University be
talking about diversity equity and
inclusion and then all of a sudden
Bernie Sanders and The Young Turks are
like nobody even thinks Equity is a real
thing that is the perfect example of
exactly what I'm saying there is no
ideology it is whatever the thought
leaders say on a whim so when Bernie
Sanders goes on Bill Maher and says I
think we want equality of opportunity
then all of a sudden they all start
going yup yup yup I've always been for
this
you could if you got Bernie Sanders to
come out and advocate for laissez-faire
capitalism they would all of a sudden be
like we've always been in favor of
capitalism we're not socialists that is
what wokeness is
fire away Ian I have a bunch of
questions too I saw you you said uh it
is the modern left liberal culture you
have left slash liberal as if it's one
thing so how do you like what's what is
this left thing mean exactly left
liberal is that the same exact thing uh
because that's a definition I want in
order to understand your definition is
it's left liberal is a tribal reference
that's why it's left liberal because the
the political left is characterized by
this group this how can I want radical
change not no they don't want radical
change
not even Progressive okay because you if
you can be uh a neolib and be woke yeah
you can be a progressive and be woke you
can be a socialist it's just are you
adhering to the cult-like structure of
this the current thing of the of current
thing that's that's a that's a great way
to frame it do you adhere to current
thing yes or no if you do your woke if
you don't you're not that's a real
simple way to put it so here's a
question I have
um I'm not disagreeing with your
interpretation of wokeness but I feel
like it must have started in fairly
recent history would you correlate it
2008 rise of social media it is yeah and
that's that's factually proven
um we went over this years ago with Zach
Goldberg put up the Lexus Nexus data
showing the rise of certain terminology
appearing in newspapers around the rise
of social media and what ends up
happening is you get these academics to
a hammer everything looks like a nail
and they're like hey these terms come
from Academia oh oh man this proves it
and then people of course like listening
to academics so even people who are
anti-establishment will see some Rogue
academics and be like ah the
intellectual dark web they must be very
smart know what they're talking about
but they mostly don't I mean they do to
a certain degree with all due respect
but I had this conversation as I
mentioned numerous times with Peter
pagosian and James Lindsey years ago
where I said I I grew up on the internet
I watched all of these things happen I
certainly understand critical race
theories emergence Frankfurt School
marched into the institutions and all
that stuff but what they don't
understand is
it could have been any ideology at all
any ideology but the social media
algorithms
favored these particular phrases for
money making reasons that's why that's
why Libertarians founded it is said I am
told because I had friends who worked
for mike.com that the guys who started
were like Ron Paul Libertarians and when
mike.com was first started it was very
anti-anti police brutality very pro-run
Paul very pro-libertarian and then over
a few years it became totally leftist
and woke because it was just chasing the
algorithms the reason the algorithms
were made was not because it was a
conscious effort by infiltrators at
Facebook it was because advertisers said
here are no no words and that's just a
runaway train it happens to align with
one ideology it didn't come from that
ideology so the path of Silicon Valley
was really techno libertarian to woke
yes so it's it's it's really simple if
you think about it an Advertiser like
Coke goes to Facebook and says you've
got you've got five posts okay one is
screaming to mercilessly beat white
supremacists one is screaming to
mercilessly beat Communists one is
screaming to Mercy beat white people or
whatever and they're like no one
complains when someone makes fun of
white people so we don't care about that
but that white supremacist stuff's got
to go and then everyone agrees like yeah
we really don't want that on the
platform
half the people agree the anti-white
stuff has to go so you start seeing that
this leads to a rise an inverse rise in
white nationalist ideology because all
of a sudden on social media they're
actively saying in their rules you're
allowed to insult white people Facebook
did this Facebook I think it was
Facebook forgive me if I'm wrong but
they said that you are allowed to
criticize groups if they are coming from
positions of power which resulted in a
whole bunch of insane posts and then all
of a sudden they got rid of it and then
a bunch of feminists who are saying kill
all men started getting banned and they
got angry about it saying we are allowed
to do this but but simply put
if a comedian makes about a white person
nobody cares comedian makes fun of a
black person people are going to have an
issue with it advertisers only care
about that it has nothing to do with
cultural Marxism it has to do with them
saying look we get a hundred complaints
when the comedian makes fun of black
people we get zero compliance and they
make fun of white people or we get
complaints from like seven people
conservatives don't care they don't
boycott they mind their own business and
everyone kind of Chuckles so we have no
problem with our ads appearing on that
stuff that weight causes the shift it is
not because the ideology took over it is
because for it is a hyper amplification
of the fact that people don't like
racist things and tolerate
things that that are targeting men or
targeting white people
Etc this gives rise to intersectionality
which gives rise to all the other
disparate ideologies but it also
explains exactly why woke people
seemingly change their minds every day
as to what they really believe because
they don't believe anything so the terms
that uh ultimately gave us the
algorithms that we have now or in the
the terms of services that we have now
were directly correlated from basically
who was complaining the loudest like if
I saw something I didn't like and
identified it because you know I'm
female so I think that's offensive that
that sort of early intervention in uh
the social media Marketplace is what
directed this yes mostly it's basically
that you take some young person they're
bored no one knows them no one cares
about them and they want likes they will
find a way to get those likes one of
those ways is to post nudes or something
so young girls are posting scantily clad
images getting lots of likes and
followers it sure feels good when
everyone's following you I was at VidCon
on seven years ago and I remember seeing
these like little kids were talking to
each other and one kid goes you have 80
followers how like that's creepy yeah I
wonder where those kids are now all they
cared about was their follower account
some people find through politics now
because here's how I described it you
know like eight years ago
the intersectional feminists are
basically like white blood cells it's an
autoimmune disorder we all agree racism
is bad it is it is detrimental to a
functioning economy we need to find a
way to work together the example of this
is how we ultimately got the civil
rights movement and the story as I'm
told is Lyndon Johnson I think it was
Johnson had staff members who were black
and he needed his dog taken home and
they were like we can't and he's like
why not they're like because we can't
use any facilities anywhere we have a
dog with us we won't be able to do
anything and he was like what do you
mean like because of segregation we
can't even stop for gas or go to the
bathroom and he was like okay that's a
problem because I got to get stuff done
and I need your help so the the nature
of the economy leads people being like
okay this doesn't work
so naturally we all say these things are
bad
so when it comes to social media people
are trying to find ways to get clicks
and get likes well everyone agrees on
this one thing so then you get young
people saying if I say one if I say this
thing I'll get clicks police brutality
videos go viral but you add a component
of racism and it goes quadruple viral so
people start spamming the stuff to make
money and generate traffic and it
creates a self-fulfilling prophecy
creating young people built on this
ideology who are inundated with this
crackpot algorithmic garbage and that's
why their ideas make no sense are are
not coherent and it's a cult all they
want to do is say what they need to say
to fit in that's why jenkiewer comes out
and goes Bernie Sanders is Right
equality of opportunity the whole time
it's like my guy you were just out
talking about Equity like a year ago
what happened no Bernie Sanders said so
and he's got more status than he does so
you got to adhere to whatever the status
status quo is I felt like before social
media it existed still but you didn't
see it they were like I remember 911 and
everybody was on board go get Saddam and
his weapons of mass destruction like the
message of the day was Saddam Hussein
bad everyone just put it put that
Ukraine flag in their bio and went with
it and like but no one knew how crazy it
was at the time because we didn't have
social media to see ourselves in action
and now you can obviously see people
falling into this narrative whether I
guess far left narrative view of college
this is radical
like gave us an individual way to to
track the data right like I saw that you
posted in favor of this issue and you
got a lot of likes so that makes me
question whether or not I should
challenge you on it because it seems
like all of our mutual friends support
you and it also explains their tactics
the reason why they try shaming you and
doing these Brigade campaigns because
they're trying to use negative social
pressure to make you do what they want
or give give them what something you
have because they're looking for the
same thing but there does there does
seem to be some sort of
um you know Marxist or left cultural
element that is complementary to it
because that's what social media is
picking up and in three years it won't
be in three years it'll be something
different well that would be amazing and
refreshing well I mean look at what
jankugur is saying literally right now
quality of opportunity that's
classically limited it's definitely
become a little bit of an outlier and
like difficult too now I know this is
exactly what wokenessa is the fact that
Bernie Sanders didn't know what Equity
was this this is the perfect example
Bernie Sanders on Bill Maher he gets
talked about what it is he doesn't know
and then says uh I think uh I don't know
I we want equality of opportunity
because he didn't know what he was
talking about right then all of a sudden
they go I I I I I agree I've always
agreed with that it's like bro that's
not Marxism that's Classical liberalism
that's what we've been arguing for I
want to see that happen I mean if that
is if that's what's coming down floating
down the river
of of wokeness that would be fantastic
it will not change the fact that these
people are violent cultists wow so what
will end up happening is they'll say do
you agree with me or not in this
instance you'll be like well I do like
equality of opportunity and then they'll
slowly lower their crowbar and say okay
you're like me and then they'll go and
attack someone else they're zombies it's
social zombism they go from person to
person they infect you with their
ideology which is it's it's there's not
even an ideology they infect you with do
what we say or it will be painful for
you then the person says I'm just going
to do whatever I'm told otherwise it'll
be painful for me and they continue to
spread that's why zombies that's why
they go from California to Arizona and
everything keeps happening they flee
because of how bad it is but keep
bringing it with them it's zombism so is
there a chance that that what what
wokenesses will ever be something
positive will it ever be positive if
it's just cultural Trends the current
thing racism is bad right yep fighting
against racism is a good thing yep these
people are operating under that premise
and it is nightmarish
so so they're always going to be
fighting against something they have to
hate something yep they have to be
against something and conversely many on
the right are exactly this and that's
why people can't define what woke is
it's a culture of hate is what it sounds
like every Everybody tries to Define
woke in some way and I'm surprised I see
so many people doing these long-winded
paragraphs about post-modernism and
intersectionality and all these things
and I'm like
these are probably people who only
recently started following the stuff
because I've been tracking this stuff
for for a while now and there are many
people have been following it longer
than I have
but I'm like
seven years ago I mean what was it seven
years ago when I did that video for
Sargon of akkad on his channel what we
defined as woke was dramatically
different
very very different it wasn't it was not
what it is today
I mean you you look at the rapid
transformation of you know saying like
kids shouldn't get sex changes which
then becomes kids aren't getting sex
changes which then becomes they get it
but it's rare why are you mad too it's
happening it's a good thing it's not
that the ideology is like they're trying
to take over it's that there isn't one
it just changes yeah I sense a dialectic
in in woke it's like a false adherence
to a dialectic whatever that's a simple
way to explain there's always this and
that in the idea of like the other
there's this like it was Saddam Hussein
in 2003 and now it's with Vladimir Putin
or it's white people or it's the rich
people or whatever but like if you're
gonna fall into this Us and Them mindset
you're basically falling into a woke
pattern we got a super chat from uh
Katia says Tim it's simple the left
appeal to Authority the right
individually that's what what uh what's
woke don't overthink it that's a good
way to put it too the left is basically
do are you in with current thing or not
and the right is kind of like
you know I think for myself what's
really splitting everybody is the
internet has allowed for the zombies to
coalesce and for the individualists to
expand their knowledge base and and you
know yeah have a voice to them people
that can hold multiple truths at once
like think oh Vladimir Putin's a bad guy
and zielinski's a bad guy it's okay to
think that you don't have to pick a side
here or they're both good guys you don't
have to pick a side like here actually
Ukraine's a really good point
under what Marxist theory is the war in
Ukraine written about or supported
it there isn't it's simply put nothing
in these lettuce ID ideologies has
anything to do with Ukraine yet for some
reason these people are all pro-ukraine
war they are very much has nothing to do
with leftism in fact you could argue
that true leftist ideology opposes War
the idea of collectivism wouldn't exist
with interventionism or
interventionalism whatever to call it
this is good evidence
that these people don't actually adhere
to any kind of ideology they just do
what the machine says to do current
thing current thing current thing is
pro-ukraine so we're pro Ukraine no
matter what it means this is how you end
up with Hassan criticizing the
military-industrial complex and
supporting the war in Ukraine at the
same time so bizarre because there's no
ideology there it's just
look they're they're looking at the
system like
logic doesn't matter what matters is all
that you agree so if the left used to be
about the military industrial complex is
bad and that artifact remains but today
you have to be pro-ukraine they will say
both things are true at the same time
despite the fact that they can't be
does the relationship wokeness have with
social media and the internet mean that
someone could use it to steer wokeness
in a certain direction like if you got
something trending you could decide what
wokeness is going to support yep
absolutely I remember I was at a protest
for occupy for uh Trayvon Martin in New
York and they were going to march to One
Police Plaza Occupy Wall Street
activists showed up went to the front of
the March and then started Fanning
people in a different direction and
brought them to Wall Street instead and
then once this huge crowd of people were
at Wall Street these people being dumb
as a box of rocks who were just doing
whatever they were told started
protesting Wall Street it was hilarious
to watch they were climbing on the ball
and they were like where are the 99 and
then one of the organizers for the
Trayvon protest was like what happened
well you didn't realize these people
didn't show up because they cared about
anything they showed up because people
told them that's what you're supposed to
do these people don't have lights on
upstairs they're just going I don't know
I'll just tell me where to stand and the
Occupy Wall Street activists knew this
I used to I used to tell people this is
really funny
when you'd be when you'd be at a March
in New York City and this is knowledge
for anybody who lives in New York or was
ever near a large leftist March if you
so I'm a journalist and I'm filming with
my camera and I have no interest in
organizing this March the funny thing is
the March is going forward and on
numerous occasions the journalists in
front will turn to the left to get a
wide shot from an angle and the crowd
would follow them and make the wrong
turn down a side street
because all of these people thought was
those people are turning I follow them
the person behind them says I follow him
I follow him I follow him and they all
just March in the wrong way and the
organizers would be like wait wait wait
stop turn around turn around and then
halfway down the block everyone would
stop and get all confused and then start
turning around and then go the other
direction it was hilarious that's what
right foot it's part of why I I hated
religion in my early life is this Faith
blind adherence to Faith Like willing to
believe that whatever we're doing is for
a greater good that I don't even
understand but I'm gonna do it and I'm
gonna follow that guy like that to me is
religion I never liked it I understand
now that you can believe in things that
you can't prove that's not necessarily
evil critical thinking that that element
needs to be there it's yeah yeah yeah
because people will take that faith and
use it for their own Advantage yeah I
would say I would think the religions
that are exactly talking about the ones
that say don't use your critical
thinking don't question us at all like
if you were questioned theoretically if
you're a religious leader you can work
with someone and have a discussion and
your values still surface at the top of
the conversation I think that's true
stronger I think about it this way
imagine there's a group of people in the
middle of the street
and then all of a sudden there's a bang
and every single one of these people
starts running North
what do you do
take cover get out of the way Run Run
West yeah get out of the way yeah why
run with the crowd oh yeah no just get
out of the what you're supposed to do is
take an is assess the situation as
quickly as possible
when so I tell the story about when I
was in Venezuela you're the National
Guard here a few blocks up you had the
protesters there was a bang and the
protesters all started running North
and then I ran West yeah I do not want
to be in between these two groups why
would I run with them but a lot of
people are really dumb so there's a run
in the direction the other people are
running and you see them in the movies
you can be running into the fire a
little show like in the movie guys in
like Africa running through the Savannah
and like he's getting chased but he just
keeps running straight in a straight
line and the car's gaining on him or
whatever it is right behind you dude run
to the left like do something unique
don't follow along well energy
Prometheus no just Clips the giant ship
is like a donut that's rolling and the
woman runs straight she's like ah and
I'm like run to your right what are you
doing get out from under it that's bad
yeah in your example in your example
these people are thinking I heard a bang
so I have to get away from that they're
not thinking about the other things that
are threatening them they're not
thinking about the difference exactly
like and that's that's wokeness that's
crazy is is wokeness a religion it is a
non-theistic religion okay so it is it
is characterized by a lot of tenets of
of uh I I should say behaviors that are
associated with religion but there's no
core structure or ideology so it's
completely Hollow okay on the outside if
you were to take woke people and a
religious group you'd be like hey they
have very similar Tendencies but then
you would find that wokeness has no
morals they don't believe in morals they
have no core ideology they say random
things and they're dangerous they're
violently adherent to their nothing all
it is is connection to each other if the
group says so you do it in fact
I'm not talking about
religious groups in the sense that they
act like woke people like antifa I'm
saying in the sense that there is a
collective structure and a community
but true religious people are not
mindless zombies mindless zombies can't
have religion but anybody who's watched
this show has seen numerous people who
are devout and and have faith who are
not zombies sure they like they think
about why they believe this stuff they
have a reason they believe it so I think
it's possible that you know you this
this zombie-like mentality has existed
in many different groups sometimes it
possesses a religion right now it's
possessing a political faction
interesting and it's existed probably
throughout history but with the rise of
social media it's not been as obvious or
prevalent and theoretically if you
control social media right now you can
control the direction of whatever
artificial degree right because we've
talked a little bit about the element of
some sort of negative feedback loop here
yeah we can't make it positive yeah I I
don't think there's any kind of positive
outcome from a Mindless zombie cult fair
enough you know like zombies can work
together in in the sense that they all
run in the same direction and will
attack and destroy
but that's the only thing they do so if
your goal is to wipe out a city
unleashing a horde of zombies is a
really great way to do it
San Francisco
or you know if you're China for instance
and you want to uh promote Tick Tock
which then zombifies young people and
creates more people that are Mindless
zombies yeah I haven't seen any creative
value like I see the destructive value
of hordes of mindless people or just not
anyone called mindless but people that
are obsessed with like being victims
like victim mentality that kind of thing
I haven't seen anything creative really
come out of it I've seen movies made
about it that aren't very good
I would say I have seen some creative
things but it's bad it's bad art it's
bad stand up bad comedy bad movies bad
it's awful I think this the mindset that
I'm a victim is just lead leads to
destruction it only can if you think
you're you're at you're you're suffering
and You're Gonna Lose or that you're
losing You're Gonna Lose You you need to
have a positive winning attitude to win
and there's not even any nobility in it
I mean you know sometimes you see like a
noble martyr I don't see any of that
it's just whiny terrible culture
it's just it's just a mob it's a
pitchfork mob and here we are whining
and complaining about it what it's
infective God that's the problem yeah
but but you must understand uh you can a
controlled burn can stop a wildfire yeah
we're having intelligent conversation
about it yeah we're picking it apart
this is why leftists don't go on shows
sometimes you'll get liberals and
left-like individuals they will do it
sometimes but overwhelmingly they don't
because their only goal is to fit in
with the cult you can't do that by going
on someone's show that is not in the
cult all that does is damage your cult
status
there's going to be an interesting
debate coming up with Clint Russell and
a leftist I'm excited about that I think
oh he announced it on the show who's the
left I think it was Vox no it's Destiny
oh it is Destiny yeah Destiny's not a
leftist he
he's a liberal he's about as Centrist as
you get I love that guy man he's he's
observant and what's up to Steve
yeah he just kind of calls what he sees
I like him that's good yeah I mean he's
a liberal he's been in the show we
disagree on policy but even like before
the show it's like we agree on on a
whole lot because he may have different
political views he leans more
authoritarian than most of us yeah but I
wouldn't I don't know if I'd call him an
authoritarian maybe because he said we
one of the things that really stood out
was when he said a crisis is the perfect
time to force change in a society and
I'm like it's very authoritarian do you
know it is yeah my attitude is like you
shouldn't manipulate people in their
time of need but he was like when else
would you do it and I'm like yeah not in
a crisis when you ask them to vote no
it's good that you have this perspective
now you see how the other side thinks
yeah yeah and acknowledging that that's
a good time to do it doesn't mean that
he's instructing people to do it he's
just saying this is when it is this is
when someone don't see an ideal time to
do it and therefore anytime we go into
crisis you can now assume that there are
people who are saying I will now
introduce change there's a big
difference between having it as an
observation and like advice yeah
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time